um
and okay we will continue now to our
cherry on the top of the event the
presentation of
dr greg sadler about meditations
on anger thanks i'm glad to be back here
at the new acropolis if only virtually
it's a short drive
but you know it's not one that we could
easily do in covid times
but hopefully uh you know sooner or
later we'll all be back to
something like normal so it's
you know i i hadn't realized this when
uh jill pointed it out that
it's by the end of this it'll already be
his uh birthday in in rome
so that that's kind of a cool feature
there um
there's a lot of wisdom that can be
drawn from the
meditations and i'm going to focus on
anger which is mentioned in the very
first line of the book
i'm not sure if everybody realizes this
but in those
meditations on gratitude he talks about
varys and and varys he's crediting for
two things
showing him good character
kalo ethas right and what it means to
have good temper and the word there is
orgaton meaning he he was without anger
he was without organ
um he showed how to react to things
without losing your your cool there's
there's a sort of a basic stoic
point to the entire work which you see
in book 12 where
marcus says it's time you realize you
have something in you
more powerful and miraculous than the
things that
affect you or create passions in you and
make you dance like a puppet so
you know if we're using this book part
of it part of the goal of stoicism in
general but this book
as well is to become more self-moved
movers more
in charge of ourselves less driven by
external circumstances
anger is one of those emotions that is
kind of paradoxical
in that when we're feeling angry you
know we are out of control we are
subject to a passion but we often think
that we're in control
we're being very rational we don't like
other people telling us that we're not
you know as seneca says anger will get
angry even with the truth itself if the
truth contradicts anger
and so you know this is an emotion
that's very important for
the stoics they think and we don't
necessarily have to agree with this
entirely
that it's uh inherently problematic
there's no good use
or instance of anger i kind of think
marcus goes along with that more or less
um anger's basic conception includes
this desire to
to retaliate to literally impose
suffering
in return on another person and
it wasn't just the stoics who were
worried about this so were the
platonists or were the aristotelians or
the epicureans
this is a a constant problem the stoics
viewed it is even more problematic
because it's disruptive to that
that rational part of our self which
should be
running the show what they call the you
know the leading or ruling part the
hegemony cone
the rational part epictetus also calls
it the pro-racist the
faculty of choice and anger you know
seduces
this and the stoics developed a number
of insights and practices useful for
understanding and
dealing with and and in some cases
getting rid of entirely
our emotion of anger it's clear that
marcus himself
did still get angry because he's got all
these you know
admonitions to himself that we take
advantage of
in reading his book and applying it and
there's a lot of um
you could call them general points where
he's
he's talking about something not just
specific to anger
which we can apply to anger i'll just
give you two of those
as examples in book 4
chapter 7 he says get rid of the
judgment you are rid of the i am hurt
get rid of the i am hurt
and you're rid of the hurt itself so you
know that can apply to
dealing with sadness or disappointment
grief that can also apply to
anger if if we can short circuit that
you know
automatic reasoning that goes from i'm
hurt
and adds into it i shouldn't be hurt
because this other person is a jerk who
did this thing to me
and then you know the next thing that
comes along the lines may i should make
them hurt too
if we can short circuit that i am hurt
we can avoid
getting angry even when people are
deliberately trying to hurt us we don't
have to we don't have to allow them to
to do that jill brought up reminders
that marcus has
about it's pretty soon you're going to
be dead everything passes away
you know look at the histories of
ancient people
and think about all the stuff that
they're doing look around at all the
people doing things today all this
is going to be gone that can be quite
helpful if
you don't like to spare and say oh well
there's no point to it all
if you can look at it in the proper way
that can really help you
to ameliorate anger you know you can say
well is this really the the time and
place for me to take the final stand
and you know make sure that everybody
knows i'm not happy with this
or can i say well you know tomorrow i'm
going to feel differently about this
uh things are going to change and in the
long run it's not going to matter that
much anyway
those those are helpful things i i think
he also has a lot of
useful places where he talks directly
about anger
and i think one that you're you're all
probably familiar with is in book
11 chapter 18 where he has
those those nine brief prescriptions he
says they can't they come from the muses
and then he adds a tenth one in from
apollo but
he's also smuggled in an 11th one in
there as well
of the nine that he starts with eight of
them apply directly to anger
i don't know if anybody's noticed this
because only some of them directly
reference it but
most of them apply directly to this this
experience of it
so the first one he says you know my
relationship to other people that we
came into the world for the sake of one
another
or from another point of view i came to
be their guardian right so that's a way
of reminding yourself
i'm not here just to get what i want
i'm supposed to actually be taking care
of other people or at least getting
along with them maybe if i'm not
in charge and getting angry is not going
to help with that
then you know the third one if they're
right to do this you have no right to
complain
and if they aren't they do it
involuntarily out of ignorance this is i
think
a stoic idea that many of you are
already familiar with
the stoics thought that most of the time
when people are being
jerks or insulting or unfair pick
whatever you want abrasive
it's because they they're mixed up they
don't understand what a human being
ought to be doing and there might be
some cases
he's even holding out cases where maybe
they're doing the right thing i don't
know you know if they are then
it doesn't do any good for me to get
angry with them but if
it's the wrong thing i shouldn't be
feeling anger i should be feeling
something else
instead the next one he says
you've made enough mistakes yourself
you're just like them
even if there's some that you've managed
to avoid so like you might
lord it over them at least i'm not a
scumbag like this guy over here
he says you have the potential for that
you're a potential scumbag a scumbag in
the making
even if coward has kept you from them or
fear of what people say or
some equally bad reason so if we if we
apply that that can help us out quite a
bit you know realizing that we ourselves
do a lot of the same things the fifth
one he says
you don't know for sure it's a mistake a
lot of things are means to some other
end
you have to know an awful lot before you
can judge other people's
actions with real understanding the
implication there is that
if we don't really understand why
another person is
saying something you know tweeting
something on on twitter we're not
looking at the context or we you know we
overhear a tiny part of a conversation
we probably shouldn't allow ourselves to
get
upset about it we should look for more
information
then you know if we're going to get
upset we should get upset with you know
full knowledge of what we're what we're
angry about
um number six he talks directly about
anger he says when you lose your temper
or even feel
irritated so it's not just like totally
losing it it's even when you're starting
out with this
human life is very short before long all
of us will be laid out side by side
you know in the same common
whatever it's going to be cemetery you
know universe that's chewing us up and
turning us
turning our little bits into other
things you know
fishes worms whatever whatever it is
number 70 says it's not what they do
that bothers us that's a problem for
their minds not
ours it's our own misperceptions discard
them
be willing to give up thinking of this
as a catastrophe and your anger is gone
how do you do that by by recognizing you
suffered no
no disgrace nothing has affected your
soul and let you unless you've allowed
it in there so
you know consider like when the bus is
late or
uh somebody doesn't treat you the way
that you like at a restaurant or when
you get your
you know your meal to go you know they
didn't put the one thing that you really
ordered that meal
for that's not a catastrophe it's not
affecting you in any moral
sense right and actually it's an
opportunity for you to
not lose your temper and start to
improve your character
rather than indulging the worst parts of
it
in number eight he tells us how much
more damage anger and grief
do than the things that cause them and i
think that's a great insight
anger you know for most of us it's not a
fun emotion to feel
it's it's difficult to to deal with
some people can get addicted to it and
then it does actually feel good for them
then you're really badly off getting
angry
in many cases and acting on that anger
does more damage to you than the thing
that you're
angry about in number nine he says
kindness is invincible provided it's
sincere
not ironic or an act what can even the
most vicious person do if you keep
treating him with kindness
kindness and gently set him straight
correcting him cheerfully at the exact
moment that he's trying to do you harm
this is an important uh idea here you
know
we don't have to to say that everything
everybody does is a-okay
we can say you're doing the wrong thing
but we don't have to use
anger this is a case that seneca makes
as well we don't have to use anger
as our unreliable tool for
getting ourselves to do that i think a
lot of people
in our world today do think that unless
you get angry you're not going to oppose
injustice or you're not going to call
people out
and maybe one of the the lessons we need
to learn and one of the
crutches we need to abandon is using
anger as the thing that allows us to
to protest to to you know call somebody
out on something to
rightly impose sanctions or things like
that and then you know number 10 he says
to expect bad people not to injure
others is crazy it's to ask the
impossible the world that we live in
is a world where there's a lot of people
who are jerks who are
morally we could say damaged or
underdeveloped
we can go into all sorts of reasons why
that's the case
marcus wants us to recognize that you
know asking people
not to be that way is is really asking
for something that's not going to happen
and so if we want to be unrealistic with
ourselves we have to take
we have to take responsibility for that
or he is saying
he has to take responsibility there is i
mentioned one other thing that
he says in here that i think is really
quite insightful
he doesn't list it in his 9 or even 10
thing he says
in between the 9 and the 10 along with
not getting angry at others trying not
to pander either both
are forms of selfishness so when we're
getting angry
we're being selfish we're setting
ourselves apart from
the rest of we could call it the cosmos
in his sense
so he says when you start to lose your
temper remember there's nothing
manly about rage it's courtesy and
kindness that define a human being
those who possess strength and nerves
and guts not the angry
whiners now this is a heart's
translation which is pretty
good i like that angry whiners to react
like that brings you closer to
to impassivity and so to strength pain
is the opposite of strength he says and
so
is anger so i think this this is a
really
great passage to look at for helping us
out
there's a few others i'd like to key in
on and then we'll do some q a
and some discussion um i mentioned that
anger has this this function of
separating us
and there's there's three passages in
particular
um two of which are from book two where
he he explicitly says this
so in chapter 10 of book two he tells us
that
when we're angry we turn away from
reason
the reason that's within ourselves or
the reason that we can find in the
cosmos
with an as he calls it inward spasm
right there's this kind of jerking away
from it um
in in chapter 16 of book two he says the
soul of a person
does violence to itself when it becomes
angry and tries to injure another
he's listing a number of other things as
well that do that like trying to steal
from people
or you know but but anger he singles out
it's a way in which we become as he
calls it a separate growth
almost like you know a cancer
and we're damaging ourselves we're
damaging the
largest social fabric of relationships
that we're in
in in marcus's view we're actually
damaging the cosmos itself by
indulging ourself and separating
ourselves off
in in our anger and you know sulking in
our our rage
um he he talks about this again in book
11 and tells us that anger
actually severs us from nature and he
means nature with a capital n
right it severs us from our human nature
which is to be
you know involved with other people it
severs us from our
our larger involvement in the cosmos
so i think you know whether or not he's
right about this
you know metaphysically those can be
really helpful
things to bring in mind when we start to
get angry we can say do i really want to
separate myself off
and be contained in this you know
rageful little bubble that i'm stuck in
which is no fun to be in or do i want to
be
i have to make a choice do i want to be
connected with the rest of the world
and the cosmos
i mentioned that that he he says we
should try to realize that other people
are not doing wrong just for the sake of
doing wrong
and that it's bad for them i'll just
give you one
example of that in in book
book six and chapter 57 he says honey
tastes bitter to a person with jaundice
people with rabies are terrified of
water and a child's idea of beauty is a
ball
why does that upset you and and when
you're saying why does that upset you
it's actually saying why are you getting
angry over that in the greek
ti un zomai do you think falsehood is
less powerful than bile or a rabid dog
so why are we allowing all of these
things that
that people you know thank for the
they're wrong about it why do we allow
that to
upset us that's their problem we can try
to reason with them we can try to help
them out but
we're you know just simply getting angry
with them is pretty counterproductive
he also thinks we should focus on our
own side
look at we should be consistent we
should think about the example that we
set so you know in in book 10 chapter 30
he gives us a practice a very simple one
to do
when we see somebody doing something
that we don't like and we're getting
angry about
we should ask ourselves do we do the
same thing because if we do
well who should we be angry at probably
ourselves
at the same time right and we don't like
to get angry at ourselves
so that can help us if we if we apply
this you know cognitively we can
we can mute the emotions so to speak
um he also you know says this is in book
six
um chapter 27 how cruel to forbid people
to want what they think is good for them
and yet that's just what you won't let
them do when you get angry at their
misbehavior they're drawn to what they
think is good for them but but it's not
good for them
so show them that prove it to them
instead of losing your temper
if you just you know get mad and you
know whether you do it passive
aggressively or whether you're getting
people's faces
whatever mode of anger you've got that's
probably not going to be
very helpful compared to reasoning with
them or showing you by
they're showing them by your own example
that there's something better
he also i think many of you have
probably laughed at this passage
as i have don't be irritated at people's
smell
or bad breath what's the point with that
mouth
with those armpits they're going to
produce that odor he says
and then you know the the person he's
talking with says
yeah but they have reason they or it's
also trans they have a mind don't they
they should know
better um and and uh marcus says
well you have reason too so why don't
you use your
rational faculty and try to provide a
good example for them
and how one would do this and you know
there's a lot of ways maybe you could
like leave a toothbrush out for them
or you know deodorant and ask them what
they think about that sort of thing
rather than just getting
getting upset and yelling at them or you
know
doing all the sorts of things that we we
typically do
there's one other thing that i do want
to bring up and i i do want to be
respectful of people's times
there's a great passage in book nine
in chapter 42 and this is coming from
epictetus
it's very clearly rooted in what
epictetus himself has to say about anger
marcus says once again don't expect
people won't be bad right
but he says don't expect that they won't
be bad in determinate ways that we
we have words for certain we have
classes of people
so thieves are going to steal right as
we often say in our
our society haters are going to hate or
pick whatever other
thing you want cheaters are going to
cheat right
now we can we can classify people like
that
and we can also see people as
individuals and
both of those perspectives are are
correct at the same time right it's not
as if
we have to deny that by looking at
somebody as an individual we don't have
to say well they also are this this type
but he says if you if you look at them
as individuals
you can be gentler with them meaning
less angry with them
so you can think about for example what
virtue nature gave you to productively
deal with this
you don't have to automatically respond
to
people by classifying them in a certain
way you can think about well
what do i need in order to get by with
this you can ask yourself what real harm
am i suffering because of their
bone-headed actions
or you know misguided beliefs that they
have
on their side and then we can also think
about he says
being more realistic why didn't we
reasonably expect that somebody who
fits under this this classification say
a cheater we should probably expect a
cheater to cheat
right that's that's reasonable it's
unreasonable to
to go the other way and he goes so far
and now there's the roman emperor
talking to himself that the fault was
his
in trusting or expecting that because
he's doing the right thing they
automatically will do the right thing
you know instead of behaving the way
that they do
so we can have this sort of dual look we
can understand them as a general type
and we can understand them
as an individual who we're connected
with and and again that can help us
to avoid getting angry
with them which is is probably just
going to be counterproductive
you know the other thing that i'll say
to close this out is when when we get
angry at people who are screwing up
you know the natural reaction for them
is to get angry with us and then we're
just shouting at each other and we're
all angry and we separate ourselves off
marcus is trying to chart out a
different path for us which
is not always an easy path um i got
interested
in in all this stoic stuff to begin with
because of
trying to you know find anger management
tools for my own life
in ancient philosophy and so you know
it's it's
not i can say from experience it's not
easy to apply
if it is easy for you to apply you're
you're lucky
but for most people it's not but i think
this is uh this is all some very helpful
stuff
coming out of this uh this great book so
that's
that's all i have to say i'm happy to
stick around for some
you know questions or discussion
whatever it is that that you want to
bring up
thank you very much greg and we do have
a short time but
i would like to see if anybody has a
questions
in this topic or maybe in other topics
related to it
i have a one question yes michael uh
gregory that was an amazing presentation
thank you
thank you shira um and everyone else uh
i guess i'm wondering if there's
any one particular situation where anger
might be
a good thing in life
so seneca talks about this in on
anger the stoic view is that there isn't
any
any time when feeling anger is a good
thing but he talks about
judges needing to um fake or
feign anger to like drive the fear into
the criminal so that they're not going
to do it
what they're doing but but it's faking
it right rather than actually
being motivated by anger and and seneca
says
and i think marcus would agree with him
anything that you can do
under the influence of a emotion or
passion
you can if it's the right thing to do
then then proper practical reasoning can
lead you to doing that too
and it's going to be more reliable you
know i think we often view emotions as
kind of like uh
you know like we take a little pill to
give us some pep to do something
um but we we should be able to do it
without
without the emotion i will add
if you don't mind if we equate anger
with
lack of control over ourselves then it's
hard to imagine
any situation where anger is positive
right
yeah and maybe there is a situation a
kind of anger that is sort of righteous
anger but then again i agree with greg
that
if it's the right thing to do you can do
it also from sort of
reasoning from from the right
motivations as well
one of one of the things that makes
anger so dangerous and difficult
is that it it's almost like it includes
like part of the package the idea that
what we're doing
is the right thing in this case right
and so we make all sorts of
if we'd say well it's not okay for that
guy over there to get angry in this
situation but
me i can control it i can direct it
properly you know
it's it's it's a it's a dangerous thing
to
to uh to use i mean and i i
i have to say i don't completely agree
with the stoics on this i
i do think that i'm more tempted but you
know
in an aristotelian direction where like
maybe there could be righteous anger but
even aristotle thinks you got to be
super super careful with this emotion
thank you for the question michael i
just had one
uh question for mr sadler when he was
talking about like
um book seven
book two chapter ten exactly which
uh books
is he talking about what what what's the
name of them and
oh no these are all in the meditations
the meditations is divided
into 12 books yeah yeah
okay because i have it but it's very
small and i was thinking
well a book a book in ancient times is a
scroll that you would unwind
so meditations would be 12 scrolls that
you would have like in a bag
you know and it's just it's just a
naming convention from ancient
philosophy so
you could call them chapters if you
wanted to
um and i think there might be one
translation out there that does that
um but the typical convention is you
know there's 12 books to the
the uh the meditation so like when jill
was talking about the first
book book one is is all these you know
chapters about gratitude thanks to this
guy
thanks to this person um and then book
two is the one that begins with the
you know rise every day and say to
yourself i'm gonna have to deal with a
whole bunch of
ungrateful jerks you know but i can
remind myself of this and then
yeah they're they are pretty short um
the
the whole of the meditations is you
could you could actually like
in a long afternoon i think you could
read through the whole book
thoughtfully you know if you're going to
speed read you could probably do it in
an hour
an hour his mind is only that big yeah
small yeah and i thought maybe you had
something else
no no okay well i don't think the
purpose is to speed read it
i mean you can take one sentence from
here and meditate it
or reflect on it for a whole day right
yeah that's
it well i want to thank you greg
and i want to thank all the presenters
today
i want to thank all of you who've come
today to listen to us
and to participate in this celebration
but first of all i want to
thank marcus aurelius
i don't think he can hear me right now
according to his beliefs at least no but
um but in any case we're going to thank
him for leaving us this treasure
which is
you